outro dia eu entrei num táxi e da lei
promotoria estão de kiraly e uma triste
me respondeu você acabou de chegar em
são paulo e falei não eu moro aqui há
bastante tempo ea gente foi conversando
o resto do trajeto até determinado ponto
e me perguntou de novo mas já que você é
e aí eu perguntei pra ele você quer ser
bem se por causa do meu sotaque nem falo
que sim e aí eu achei a brecha para
responder essa pergunta e provavelmente
muitos de vocês estamos fazendo a minha
voz ela é resultado de mais de 25 anos
sem qualquer feedback eu dirigi me ao
show numa ajuda mas eu sou um tipo de
surdez diferente do que a maioria
conhece quem você já deve ter ouvido
falar de surdos e usou a língua de
sinais a libras ou também as pessoas que
vão perdendo a audição por causa da
idade ea gente tá aumentando o volume de
voz para falar com elas mas entre um
grupo e outro existem vários tipos de
perda auditiva várias formas de se
comunicar e deixou os que como eu tenho
uma voz meio estranha e é esse grupo é
chamado de juros realizados com tanto
pra vocês brevemente a minha história eu
nasci um vídeo normalmente ea índia aos
nove anos de idade
eu pedi anos eu por causa de caxumba
eu beijo de ser um assunto totalmente ea
partir daí a minha comunicação faço é se
através da leitura labial eles silentes
nela e através da voz porque até os nove
anos já tinha aprendido a falar mesmo
que comece com tempo ética e nem se o
tac que deixa a minha voz meio estranha
mas tudo bem
engraçado como as pessoas reagem quando
eu falo em um determinado ponto da
começa que o já deficiente auditiva
a gente está convencida meia hora aí a
pessoa cria coragem pergunta de onde a
cia ataca e aí eu explico eu tenho
deficiência giba eu junina e aí a pessoa
toma
é muito engajada ela parou de falar e
ela fica me olhando
até que de repente na volta para a
itália
meu deus como que botar lá com vocês eu
não tava aquela linguagem das mãos de
assis pelo fundo deixa o rio tem que ser
mais embaixo é possível aceitar que a
gente continue sujeito que ajudou a
fundar dois minutos nesse projeto
o engraçado é que eu sempre vi
brasileira quando no exterior deixando
os brasileiros sempre reconheci o
brasileiro fala inglês não chegou mas
existem letreiro na festa de chutar
outro jogador vem do be visitam da minha
irmã que mora lá e aí vou comprar o café
me sentindo a próprio turista é meu
inglês fantástico chega a pagar aqueles
papéis da lei em inglês morning light
lekman cape to isso responder brasileira
né vamos conversar porque eu também sou
eu tava do país gente ele estava falando
meu jogo e depois sobre o islã e aqui no
brasil eu sou estrangeiro tempo todo ela
investiu bastante o meu nome mesmo em
laquila batendo machico o meu nome é
laksmi aos 30º
acho que o brasileiro em algum momento
durante toda a minha vida a minha
comunicação cinema através da leitura
labial lá atrás quando eu falava a
respeito do papel observa explodiu em
português
hoje em dia um de maio que vai refletir
label fechava se já leu lado de alguns
jogadores de futebol na praia clube joão
percebe que estava conversando durante
jogo se quiser eu já fiz isso e já fez
até a de ser um filme inteiro dos é de
cachorro que o ajude na chefe de pedidos
foi muito bacana desce são ações muito
especiais nisso não serve pra gente
falar do que significa a comunicação
através da leitura labial muita gente
como eu não tenho notícia nenhuma
leitura labial para se comunicar
é um talento natural do ser humano é
muito normal você não está convencendo
uma pessoa detém estela entender é muito
melhor que se vai falando com ela um
telefone e no telefone você não tá bem
da pessoa e aí você começa a subir
aquelas gates proteger leite label não
tem nenhum segredo você lê o lago da
pessoa no meio de lado a posição da
língua movimento da língua ea expressão
do rosto a especial de hoje é muito
importante porque a gente não consegue
perceber a internação da voz
a gente pega pela inspeção do rosto e
para falar com uma pessoa que mais tem
cura label não tem nada demais
gostava de preferência de repente ela
tem de evitar colocar a mão na frente da
boca
tento falar um pouco mais devagar mas
sempre de naturalidade e significa
alinhamento a gente vai espirrar
eu sou um bom exemplo de que vocês não
devem se beijar não se entender
ela vai despedir pr piche não relaxa
falar com ela com naturalidade a mesma
coisa vale se você não entendeu chubb
analisado e falando porque a nossa voz
estranha véspera bush
a pior coisa que pode acontecer é
preciso saber se esse merda eu não
causei aparelhos auditivos explica a
minha perda realmente é muito profunda e
não têm onde ser residual que possa ser
utilizada para amplificar o som porque é
isso que o aparelho auditivo como ele
tais ele amplifica o chão como se a
pessoa tivesse um alto falante na orelha
mas porque tenho uma pergunta um pouco
menor do que a minha ele pode ter morte
band dário mas farão se a pessoa se
adaptar houve com ele porque não é assim
a pessoa põe o aparelho aqui saiu vindo
perfeitamente a pessoa tem que se
acostumar a ouvir com ele o apoio do meu
marido ele tem 98 anos pessoas
hiperativas super bem com a vida já que
ele começou a pegar do chão quando ele
tinha mais ou menos 90 e aí ele precisou
colocar aparelho auditivo ele poder
conversar com a família nunca gorando a
gente e eu me lembro que a gente chegava
na casa dele e batalhas dentro da boca
aí fica proibida num aperto no bolso da
jaqueta de doug ellin do palavra cantada
que é a cumplicidade que só um
deficiente auditivo tem com o clube joão
pessoa com deficiência do time entende
mesmo que você não consiga usar o
aparelho porque a cidade é privado é
muito barulhenta mas já tem que usar se
acostumar com ele pra poder entender o
que a gente está falando
e aí com o passar do tempo e testou
vários aparelhos antigos se adaptou e
hoje eles o aparelho tempo tão deles até
mais que eu como ele no meu caixa poderá
mais profunda com aquela um aparelho
movido não resolviam a minha pela china
então me comunicar através de leitura
labial e tudo bem
a minha vontade de me comunicar é muito
maior do que qualquer obstáculo imposto
pela sua vez acontece pra vocês que se
insinuem vontade enorme de ver porque o
som é o que nos conecta o mundo ao nosso
redor é o que põe norte sentido de
comunidade
eu tenho é que a gente fala é o que nos
conecta e eu senti a falta de ritmo
eu senti a tata desse parte desse
universo sonoro que a gente vive tão de
gesso e aí eu lembro que fui procurar
uma tecnologia um pouco mais moderna um
pouco mais poderosa que esses aparelhos
auditivos comuns chamada implante
coclear
o empate ficou claro ele é formado por
duas partes uma interna que a gente
coloca por cirurgia e outra externa que
é capitão e seu ambiente e manda para a
parte interna a parte interna é composta
de componentes eletrônicos que conduzem
o som até a parte do vídeo que no meu
caso não funciona que a coca cola em
seasons estimulam eletronicamente e
manda o jogo até o cérebro que
interpreta que a gente ouve e os chamo
esses componentes estrelas sonoros
segunda linha
a parte externa ela pode se tirar a
companhia viu na seqüência a gente põe
tira o certo ea gente já o tempo todo e
tirar só pra de mim tomar banho acontece
pra vocês que eu tive quando vai me
incomoda
por exemplo em finais de campeonatos de
futebol e povo começa entre os fogos de
artifício que não acaba mais aguentando
trabalho eu preciso me concentrar em
alguma coisa e upshaw da galera começa a
falar do último capítulo do seriado que
tá todo mundo assistindo a ifá longe eu
vou precisar tirar mas eu gosto muito de
jogar em plant então pra todo mundo fala
que hoje tempo todo em batidas de quando
e se a grande verdade é que o implante é
claro ele tem idade muito variáveis
no meu caso tenho o melhor resultado
esperado em dande e consigo falar no
telefone eu consigo ouvir música mas
isso varia muito de uma pessoa para a
outra porque depende do histórico da
pessoa depende do tipo de chinês
o meu e do meu caso apareciam muito eu
parto já tinha ouvido antes eu tenho uma
memória auditiva mas tem dias que também
o estado quando têm perda progressiva ou
simples o aparelho digestivo
principalmente crianças quando implantam
cedo elas costumam manter o resultado
muito favorável
em muitos casos elas conseguem ter a
aquisição da fala
o desenvolvimento da linguagem ea
compreensão auditiva de uma criança com
a mesma de dutra a mesma idade que houve
normalmente mas claro que no tempo delas
não dá pra gente comparar uma criança
que nasce o ouvinte vai crescer porque
colocou em trânsito
eu tenho afilhados england de parte três
anos e botou o aparelho com 11 meses e o
resultado ela demorou um pouco
por exemplo ela não entende o que a
gente falava mas ela não falava
ela se comunicavam do gpl mas ela não
falava até que um dia a gente vai pra
praia todo mundo e ela viu o mar pela
primeira vez e aí sua bela olha lá era
água
repetiu água a água água ele apresente
50 mil vezes a água estivesse incrível
foi que ela não apenas entender um chão
da palavra repetiu som ela assimilou o
conceito da palavra água
de repente a água mar mas também era
piscina do hotel dela que ela gostava de
ficar tão bem era o conteúdo da garrafa
vazia o leite da mamadeira bela festa e
simplesmente emitir um som e letrada
compreendendo o mundo ao redor dela
porque isso é o que antes desde maio
especial eles nos conecta o mundo ao
nosso redor do meu caso
depois de vinte e tantos anos sem ouvir
quando eu voltei a ouvir eu ficava
encantada curso os bobos do cotidiano
porque por que voltar a ouvir pra mim
foi como voltar para casa uma longa
viagem por um país bem distante da onde
eu fui contra a minha vontade
e aí você sabe como voltar para casa
depois muito tempo que você passe
viajando
tudo que disse não dá a mínima fica em
cima mente não teve sãs e eu lembro que
eu me encantava com os blocos no
cotidiano por exemplo o tic-tac do
relógio e vai falar assinante aquele
xique xique xique marcando o tempo e
olhava aquele leve e coisa fascinante
gente
depois de tantos anos sem ouvir música
vocês conseguem imaginar como foi a
primeira vez que ouve música consegue
imaginar a sensação de ouvir música
depois de 25 anos sem poder ouvir música
especialmente porque é uma pessoa
extremamente reduzida
eu me lembro eu escolhi a música escolhe
uma música conhecida porque eu queria
poder cantar junto com os órgãos que não
saber se o entender a letra e aí eu
botei os fones de ouvidos conectados do
meu aparelho ea mesma comecei a tentar e
eu comecei a cantar lamentavelmente
alguns ia cantando muito bem isso que
aconteceu uma coisa engraçada a música
o contato estava muito mais sete do que
eu consegui imaginar e chegou num ponto
que eu já não sabia e inteligente eu não
estou imaginando a música do bim
a minha reação foi física me lembro do
meu peito afetou eu senti um gênio do
meu corpo
dei bem subir um calor assim e eu
comecei a sonhar tão alto que não
conseguia mais jogar na rússia
e aí meu coração acelerou tanto que eu
pensei meu deus eu vou emprestar agora
muito bem porque eu vou morrer feliz com
esse dado em 1096 isso os fascinantes do
dia a dia mas tudo o que ganhou um som
nesses 25 anos que tinha ficado de se
ouvir
quando eu ia pro shopping na década de
80 se chegava do shopping estacionava o
seu carro ea passear
hoje não quando você chega no shopping
tem uma cancela que deixava seu
engajamento da máquina que elas da
ticket de estacionamento e aí você entra
gente a máquina fala com você precisa
reparar a primeira vez que acabara de
falar comigo ela tinha que chamar quem
falou bem vindo o shopping total
pegue seu papel de botão retirar seu
cartão ela vai ser depois de a gente e
aí eu não saberia te responder alguma
coisa teclado
na segunda vez eu fui tirar o cartão já
não sabia que não estava lá mas eu
pensei que ela ia ficar chateada ignorar
e depois eu descobri que não nas
máquinas não liga para essas coisas são
bem resolvidas mas as pessoas não as
pessoas todas as pessoas
elas querem atenção elas querem ser
parte do grupo
elas querem poder se comunicar se
importa com a língua que elas falam nem
a forma de comunicação que elas utilizam
todas as pessoas querem se comunicar
porque todos nós é cada um de nós tem
muito a dizer e baixo ainda
escutar muita bebida
[Aplausos]